one of the most notorious murder cases
in Texas has been unsolved for more than
40 years the gunman entered the home of
Priscilla Davis in August 1976 and then
shot four people two were killed
including Davis's twelve-year-old
daughter
police began to focus on her ex-husband
Colin Davis an oil tycoon what Maureen
Maher shows us in a preview of
tomorrow's 48 hours how money made all
the difference in this case this is a
case that involves wealth sex vengeance
murder Christie jack is a former
prosecutor turned defense attorney she
grew up blocks from the scene of the
crime the 1976 shootings at the mansion
belonging to oil millionaire Colin Davis
and his flamboyant wife Priscilla
Priscilla was 5 foot 2 feisty little
blonde she had big hair and packed a
texas-sized personality in that little
frame after several years of marriage
the couple broke up Priscilla wanted 50
million dollars and had her husband
barred from the mansion and Colin was
furious as former prosecutor Jack
Strickland Cullen's right in the chest
right and he's right in the chest he
can't get in the house he can't get in
the house 1 August night Priscilla and
her boyfriend a former college
basketball player named Stan Farr came
home with friends and walked into an
ambush
a gunman dressed entirely in black
opened fire
Priscilla was shot in the chest stand
far was next when it was over
Stan Farr was dead Priscilla and a
friend were wounded and in the basement
police would discover the body of 12
year old Andrea Wilbourn Priscilla's
daughter from another marriage the DA's
office theory behind the crime was the
Cullen committed all of these crimes
because the divorce his hatred of
Priscilla was so intense that he was
going to kill her and anyone else that
stood in the way would simply be
collateral damage but there was
something the DA's office may not have
anticipated Colin Davis
well seemed to affect the case starting
the very night of his arrest you can
begin to see the special treatment
already start I mean after all you're
talking about the death of a child
but in Colin Davis's case he was allowed
not only the luxury of getting dressed
even when so far as putting on a sport
jacket there were no handcuffs he wasn't
treated like the normal suspect he
always had something to work with when
you have an innocent man
Colin bought the best lawyer there was
racehorses Hanes his worth was estimated
at about five hundred million dollars I
don't think we can underestimate the
effect that his wealth had on public
opinion
Maureen Mars with us Maureen so how did
his wealth affect this case so I think
that he was able to buy one of the first
high-priced defense teams but really
racehorses Haynes pioneered what we see
today turning your defendant into a
celebrity and villainizing the victim I
mean he hired what was then a PR team to
go out and put out good publicity about
Colin Davis he was a man accused of
killing a twelve-year-old child
and people were asking him for his
autograph as he was coming out of the
courthouse and I think you see that in
today's big trunk contains died recently
I read that the other day but where's
Colin Davis
what's up Colin Davis now lives in a
very modest home in Fort Worth and
you'll see what he's doing he's leading
a very different life than he was 20
years ago really fascinating Maureen
thank you so much Maureen's report is
part of a special 48 hours double
feature tomorrow that starts at 9:00
8:00 central her story murder in the
mansion airs at 10:00 9:00 central
that's right here on CBS